Kirra Roden hey David you've answered
live calls about interventionism before
can you talk more about your standard
for interventionism versus isolationism
when should the u.s. get involved in
other countries affairs I think this is
the sort of false choice okay
you have interventionism and then you
have isolationism but there's also
another possibility non-interventionism
right interventionism is the sort of
proactive meddling in the affairs of
other countries were very often the
United States is not involved we're
talking about this from from the point
of view of American interventionism
whereas isolationism is sort of the
deliberate and proactive putting up of
walls not literal walls but sort of
figurative walls trade walls a
diplomatic walls etc with other
countries there is something else which
is called non-interventionism
non-interventionism means we have
military alliances we have a reasonable
amount of trade thoughtful trade we have
diplomatic relations but we make it
clear that we're not going to meddle in
affairs which do not concern us between
other countries and so like with most
issues when you look at the spectrum one
side and the other side you don't really
have to pick one or the other right
non-interventionism is where I am and
and that's mutually beneficial trade
right not vulture capitalist trade trade
agreements that actually benefit the
participants including the people of the
countries certainly diplomacy but we
avoid using military action except in
cases where we are directly threatened
and that could be it could be in certain
situations extended to interests abroad
we might be asked to help in some kind
of alliance by one of our allies in
certain situations and we would be very
careful about getting involved in those
things because they can often backfire
but we would have a non interventionist
approach so I am NOT a nice
halation Asst and i am not an
interventionist I am a non
interventionist when it comes to this
issue and this this relates to a lot of
different things it relates to not only
military action but it also relates to
issues of globalization and where
products are produced and how to what
degree we protect and prop up our
industry vs. operate in a world that we
recognized recognize is globalized and
often needs collectivist transnational
solutions that is my view and I think
that increasingly non-interventionism
isn't that much of a thing I mean it's
the debate mostly focuses on are we
isolationist sort of like the extreme
libertarians that you often see are we
interventionist like the neo cons and to
what degree do we push one policy or the
other but I think actually that the best
path forward is one of
non-interventionism we've got a great
bonus show for you today become a member
get instant access to the bonus show at
david pakman.com slash membership you do
get a free david pakman show
bumper-sticker
black or white if you sign up for a new
yearly membership and use the coupon
code vote soon 18 that'll save you 40%
and we will get you a free bumper
sticker just email us after you create
your membership say I want the black one
I want the white one here's my address
and we will get those bumper stickers
out to you